you guys i'm about to unbox the second
edition of my favorite camera ever and i
honestly cannot be more excited because
i talk about this camera all the time i
use it i've traveled around the world
with it
all that being said i love this camera
the first one was perfect
and basically this is like the first one
but much better
i have a document here 5.7 k video
resolution increased bit rate enhanced
colors
improved audio recording longer battery
life increased
by up to 55 which is incredible
waterproof up to 10 meters
without a case
this is a review unit so everything that
i'm showing you is still using beta
software
but i think this might be the final
version of the hat
i don't know if i'm a hat person am i
wow that's it's a look they have some
new accessories they say that this is
the old selfie stick
there is a new stick that is on its way
we've got a new bullet time
cord a lens cap this might seem like a
very
small simple thing that you're like why
didn't the first one have a lens cap
i don't know i bought a third-party one
so it's really great that they decided
to make one that fits perfectly
from insta360 here it is hello
my friend oh my god it's personalized
hey justine that's me
we're excited for you to be one of the
lucky few who gets to try out the
insta360 one x2
first we selected this first batch of
units just for you
also they have a new insta360 branded
micro sd card
which is great because then i'll always
know that this is for
the insta360 camera i'm not even wasting
time i'm just opening the camera up
right the second
so here it is
the first thing that i've noticed is
obviously it has an lcd right here on
the front
of course it has the dual cameras which
gives you
the incredible 360 effect let's check
out that battery
oh this is so beefy
let me just show you in comparison to
the first gen
look at this battery like look at this
are you freaking kidding me huge
improvement
this does feel a little bit heavier but
honestly it's really not that big of a
deal because most of the time you have
it on the end of a stick or on some sort
of accessory
the fact that it's a little bit heavier
it i mean
look how small it is it's not like it's
actually heavy at all
let's just freaking turn it on it's
loading oh my god okay
can you see me can you see me you can
see me
this is gonna be so freaking fun
it's also a touch is it moving
yeah oh my god i'm so excited about this
again this is running beta software so
some of the actions might be a little
bit limited
at the current time of testing but i
will keep you guys posted as there are
updates or anything else
there's so much cool stuff that you can
do with this camera i just recently
after using it for several years i
finally just started transferring this
footage to my computer because you're
able to export a much
larger image and it's really amazing the
stuff that you can capture from
from this so i can only imagine like i
just talk about this camera so much
i love you say it back i wonder if this
will fit in here
oh my gosh it does there's just
something that i love so much about this
little bag
you're gonna have to find a new home
you've been replaced
it kinda smells like chocolate
it's perfect it's perfect perfect fit
it's a nice little
silicone it's like a little hat so this
is the bullet time cord
there's this handle that you can connect
to
the selfie stick where you spin it
around your head and you get a really
cool matrix style stop motion shot
but this is supposed to be a very small
yes replacement
if you don't want to use the handle oh
shut up
[Music]
so now you'll just clip this
on here for how long this is okay not
that long let me see
will i hit anything am i gonna hit
something
it's hard to say i don't think i okay
this is great
this is perfect
[Music]
okay this is freaking cool there is a
new selfie stick
but it wasn't out at the time of
unboxing this so i'll show you guys that
later
so this is the previous version so now
this is unboxed i'm gonna connect it to
my phone and get everything all set up
the firmware updated
and then take it outside to start
testing it is insta360
1x2 testing day i'm so excited we're
going to go out and do some really crazy
high action sports
stuff that you've never seen before
unlike anything
you will ever experience but you'll
experience it
here today in this video
[Music]
do you see that hi action sports what's
really cool about this
is the selfie stick will be removed in
post so automatically
it'll just kind of look like this thing
is floating in midair
do these come all the way are they
already put together yeah okay
so like if i got this right now i could
ride it like out you think i'd break it
the mini probably it's meant for up to
five-year-olds 50 kilograms
whatever that so like 125. okay i'll
just get this one are you sure
yes yes okay can i do apple pay yes
oh this is gonna be perfect thank you
[Music]
so
no
oh so what do you think happens when you
throw
any type of camera or electronic gear
with exposed lenses
20 30 feet what do you think happens
yeah i don't want to talk about it and
look look at this this
crappy gopro gopro clamp
broke in half that's why gopro
[Music]
maybe i'm not gonna pay attention
gonna test out their new bullet time
accessory to activate this it uses a
couple different algorithms so you have
to set the camera to
shoot at 3k 100 frames a second and
it'll automatically recognize as you're
swinging it to go into the bullet time
mode so i'm going to put this on here
this is gonna be the first time that i'm
gonna try it so
very nervous okay we are recording
[Music]
this is so much better
than having the handle oh god i'm gonna
get hit
don't get up because you're gonna get
hit in the head oh my goodness look how
cool this looks
that's incredible oh do you think that
i'd be able to do that
riding the scooter
we're about to find out
oh god i'm so athletic i'm so athletic
do you think i got my gold medal yet do
you think it's in the mail
maybe it might be in the mail maybe it's
lost in the mail just like my invite
just needs a birthday party
but it got lost i gotta put my stuff
down for my action sports moves
so it's not gonna be as intense as it
normally would be because i still have a
sprained ankle but i'm gonna do my best
[Music]
athletes need nourishment that's why
we're going to whole foods
for whole foods whole nourishment for my
whole body
[Music]
you need to be cool if we did like a
time lapse like a motion lapse
or something
[Music]
it's very important to fuel up with
protein when you're an
athlete such as me i'm reviewing
the footage now what's really cool about
this is i'm basically connecting to the
wi-fi on the camera
and i just brought in some of the
footage from the camera so i made this
little
time warp time lapse here check this out
imagine the cool things you could do if
you were actually doing action sports
and this is high action shopping another
really cool thing is you can change the
aspect ratio so this is in 16x9 but i
can
switch it to a one by one so it's more
of a square you could do 9x16 so it's
vertical for stories this is how i do
a lot of these different shots that i've
done over the past couple of years i
just edit these directly on my phone
on the go and then upload them being so
athletic
is exhausting oh my god i hate
everything that i'm doing right now
this is so weird
whoa what is this
i'm dizzy there may be a security person
[Music]
arriving
oh god it's still moving
fashion do you know
what olympic athletes wish that they
could do
clone themselves do you know what i can
do
clone myself does that mean i'm not an
olympic athlete
i'm not sure
[Music]
well this was quite a fun day i must say
that the insta 360 1x was my most
favorite camera ever it is something
that i
never left home without every single
trip that i have taken over the past
several years that was always the main
piece of my gear bag and now
they would have made that perfect camera
better with the insta 360 one x2
i'm speechless i mean it's my favorite
it's my favorite camera
like i absolutely love this thing so
much and it also has made me an action
sports star
so thank you gold medal
[Music]
hero